while the eyes of the world are on
ukraine the u.s is also focusing on
hidden conflicts against jihadists in
africa where at least 18 different
terrorist organizations are operating
thousands of americans are stationed at
a key military base in the horn of
africa close to some of the continent's
most dangerous trouble spots
camp lamogne in djibouti is the only
permanent u.s base in africa and our
deborah pata got an inside look
this may be a routine training exercise
but the special ops air combat men need
to stay fighting fit their job is to
rescue troops trapped behind enemy lines
stationed in high-risk locations like
camp le monde in the east african nation
of djibouti
in the air
on land
or at sea
the 4 500 strong troops at this military
base are tasked with combating the
world's deadliest al-qaeda and isis
organizations
you can see why it's of such strategic
importance over there yemen about 70
miles away and just 20 miles from here
in front of me somalia
al-shabab acts with impunity in somalia
where violent attacks have increased
isis networks are on the ascendancy
across africa conflict-ravaged ethiopia
and a shaky sudan rocked by kuz this is
one of the most volatile regions on the
continent
despite this there's been a rebranding
of america's war on terror since its
chaotic departure from afghanistan the
previous administration withdrew troops
from somalia over a year ago president
biden says he's now fighting terrorism
from over the horizon unmanned drones
periodic special ops raids and training
african forces
and it's here at camp le monde that that
approach is being put to the test
instead of boots on the ground in places
like somalia the war on terror is being
fought from a distance
but that approach has failed to stop the
growth of terrorist groups across the
continent
east africa air force commander colonel
matt bartlett says al-shabab is now one
of the most well resourced extremist
organizations in the world the risk
there would be that al-shabab
has a safe space as it were to grow the
capacity and capability the commander
general for the horn of africa william
zanner is even more candid
are you worried that somalia could be
harboring the next to osama bin laden
sure are
something in someone worse than osama
bin laden the general believes campbell
is a modest insurance policy that can
help prevent another 9 11. groups like
al-shabaab's capabilities are only
growing and from my perspective it's
only a matter of time before that
their stated intent
their desire is to is to strike the u.s
homeland
president biden is expected to make a
decision on whether or not he's sending
u.s troops back into somalia soon until
then the last thing these military
leaders want is an emboldened al-shabab
that believes all it has to do is wait
it out and wear america down like the
taliban did in afghanistan for cbs
mornings deborah patter djibouti
deborah powder thank you so much